[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want whatever we want what
do you want to talk about
uh the first time you
realized you were worthy
what is what the [ __ ] what about someone
else someone else
there are so many trigger words here
worthy of what is that [ __ ] that west
l.a [ __ ] yeah it's west la again west la
coming through
is that the conversations you guys have
at bars north of the 101
like do you cry with them you know
you're [ __ ] worthy and like you're
[ __ ]
oh every single time i get drunk i turn
into coach carter like i
will make speeches like we're all gonna
be famous
together we're all gonna rise to the top
isn't that really awkward though when
you say that and then a year later
you're the only famous one
and then all your friends like what the
[ __ ] no i just
for the record we never finished talking
about me coming back so i will always
come back here
thank you and even if it's done even if
y'all
say goodbye to jk news i will still come
here by myself
and sit here look at the keys what if
you become really super famous are you
still coming back here yes
but you're like super sure this is
homies close your eyes close your eyes
you're super [ __ ] famous now you're
getting invited to yacht parties with
leo and george connor mcgregor mark goes
hey
you want to shoot jk news for eight
hours out of your busy [ __ ] day
if i can i will hey get it come get into
traffic and join us in the morning yeah
even
morning no i won't let you i want you to
say
[ __ ] you joe you're a piece of [ __ ] yes
you guys are not on my level get to my
level
and then i go you know what guys we need
to get to sherry's level so she could
come back
yes years ago i saw anderson pack in the
on the streets and he was like what's up
and i was like dude you are such a
[ __ ] loser don't you ever say hi to
me
that means you haven't made it yet dude
[ __ ] ignore me and move on you got to
be like that
never did he say hi to you now did you
see him recently oh no he's he is he
will never say hi to me yes
differently that means he's famous no
that's not
i don't know
so bittersweet no i but no i would never
i would never i literally
you better you better i'm not gonna
allow you better even in in five years
when i have my
emmy yeah you're gonna see geo i'm like
you are
fine no i'll be like [ __ ] would you you
would have seen way more hotter tricks
by the way in your first shot
absolutely thank you baby you throw a
rock out the window you'll see a better
woman dude yeah
easy smarter stronger taller [ __ ]
beverly hills hockey
yes beverly hills hot oh yeah yeah we're
not talking about southgate hotties
you're not talking about five six too
hot we're talking three one oh yeah yeah
thank you beverly hills is is hot people
have you ever been to beverly hills yeah
i have but i don't know it's just like
they take hot people
and then they fix them even more that's
what i don't like they're like too hot
oh so then she doesn't think that so
then i'm not really hot they get their
[ __ ]
i like i like natural like so you're
like ugly
you don't like bleached [ __ ] it's
the best yes
i bleach my [ __ ] i should do that too
i haven't have you seen a bleached
[ __ ] up in person before
no can you show me yours what is it
hairs butt hairs
is that you frosted tip [ __ ] listen
let's bring that back
like faux hawk [ __ ] oh my god dude
i hear the little landing strip is
coming back like
bear [ __ ] what do you prefer on
yourself bear yeah me too
but i'm too lazy so it's not bare
anymore that's not bad at all
i can i have nothing sorry i want a bear
[ __ ] and a mom
i thought you said you lasered it i did
but it still grows back not as crazy as
before mexican
oh the mexican gene kind of kicks in
with the shield and [ __ ] i'm nervous
to get laser because i'm like what if
one day i want a bush
it'll come back it's not permanent but
it's just not gonna be as full
okay like i got my underarms mine's like
you know the dance floor
at like 1005 on a saturday you know
you don't need it it might not work it
might not come back oh
it won't work some asian girls are just
faint of hair everywhere
like just even my armpits are not that
abundant yeah yeah he doesn't have
i don't barely have hair here either one
or the other then it's either this or
this
yeah it's like either ridiculously hairy
or not hairy at all wait what's your
story
what i was i was just gonna say i'm so
down to move on
topic oh yeah do you [ __ ] i feel like
you're not a shaver either
i i keep it all nice and nice and clear
what's the earth he's what he's saying
i lasered it he didn't even laser he
he took a flame like those [ __ ]
videos where they cut everything oh god
has seen that
have you ever gotten a pube stuck in
your teeth what no
it just happened to me right now it's
happened to me like literally
i was like in the shower from a guy or a
girl or yours i think it was a guy
yours i was like like i was in the
shower and i was what is that i was like
wait did i eat a tortilla chip because
you know sometimes tortilla chips like
they'll stab your gum yeah
i felt like that i was like what what is
that what is that and then pubes two are
very wiry and bristly too yeah i know
very very firm ouch unless you have
curly hair
wait do you think someone is like super
eco-friendly and uses their own
pubes attached to a toothbrush 100 dude
there's [ __ ] weird people
i'm glad we moved on what do you want to
talk about steve
i mean why pubes when you just have
regular hair okay any other questions
you have for me then
you specifically always you specifically
how's dating going
that doesn't sound good i don't wanna i
don't wanna say too much no i know but
but cause are you in a hopeful phase and
you don't wanna jinx it here's the thing
that is is bittersweet about the
situation you know like i do have
feelings for someone
but i'm leaving to vancouver for three
months sorry i'm taking
cherry i'm taking i've had a
long-distance relationship for you i
know
but the thing is this just started it's
like well we're not ready for a
relationship
the last time that i saw you you talked
you told me that you were
so into this person is this that same
person no oh got over that one
so i'm zero to 100 real quick but
sometimes 100 to zero even quicker which
is
i'm working through it in therapy um you
change your mind like a girl changes
clothes
i wear the same thing every day you
haven't noticed that hat has been on her
for about 10 years
plus after covid with nikki and pajamas
every day i don't think that works
anymore
pajamas are hot does nikki have like one
of those like silky scents she does
she does do you no i'm naked damn
geo you are fine as [ __ ]
fine is fun it's okay in a scale of hot
right what is go to you from one to ten
she's a [ __ ] ten
without a doubt but she also likes the
natural change
oh that's right everything of her is not
real but you don't you don't have to
rate people who are just in monterey
park
you can rate beverly hills she's at
monterey park 10 but in beverly hills
she's a solid four i'm a four
she's like she's a marcapo high school
i agree no no i'm not even joking either
like i'm not even joking i think geo is
like
monterey park 10 a 10 without a doubt is
that including
looks and personality
david's trying so hard see here's
something i don't know geo as well as
y'all do so i i wouldn't be able to name
one flaw
oh i got it i got you it'll it'll start
climbing down
all right flaws one by one one by one
army clothes
okay okay
support
[Laughter]
idiot stupid [ __ ] useless
family feud we're on family field i was
just on family feud celebrity family
feud oh
mind you is steve harvey pretty cool he
is very cool and like i do stand up so
then i was like talking to him about how
i was like been watching him and
remember the steve harvey show with him
and cedric yeah
i love that [ __ ] like the best of luck
to you but he was really good people he
had the best slacks in the business
he has money yo i bet have you seen his
teeth he was giving us advice too of
like don't buy a house in l.a like buy
it in like
vegas he's at that age now where he
doesn't even do stand-up anymore he just
gives people life advice and bible
verses all the time
right and what's crazy is like the
people in the audience like it's dope
not crazy but like
um they go to see him and like he like
does like you know
funny stuff in between and like they
love it you know they love his
commentary on life i think i love it
yeah and he's been through a lot you
know the industry in in so many ways so
um we won family feud uh it was really
good
i wanted to win money for charity yeah
so at one point i was doing [ __ ]
charity and i was like listing all these
things
and it was like at the end yeah that was
you yeah i did that and
uh the question was like name one person
you would that would keep you on the
phone for hours
geo and i met right what's this oh
you're all talk no action my phone's not
ringing okay [ __ ] um
so that's flirting by the way boys
[Laughter]
did you take note he already got you
you're done whatever anyway i ended up
saying i i meant customer service
but i said tell a [ __ ] marketer but
we had to re-record it it would have
been cool if they could like because i
said [ __ ]
yeah oh okay do you feel like there's a
lot of like uh pressure on your
shoulders just because you represent a
lot of
of groups right so bisexuality uh
[ __ ] female immigrant immigrant
immigrant as well right because
chinese you're kind of like taking like
the uh
the role of that margaret show played
when i was younger hello everybody
today's video is brought to you by hbo
max
whether you're looking for some guilty
pleasures or some reality shows
serious dramas or you want a new spin on
a classic
like the gossip girls reboot hbo max
is creating premium content that has a
little something for
everyone feed your fandom with titan
season 3
or the same day premiere of suicide
squad
or catch up on the hottest newest shows
like euphoria
or generation oh and if you guys been
wondering where
rick and morty went to it's on hbo max
because i've been catching up on
episodes on that baby
and also i'm really stoked about space
jam because
that is one of my childhood favorites
and i know
a lot of people might be like you know
it's never going to beat the original
i don't know it's nostalgic but things
also have to evolve
so i'm really looking forward for that
one i might actually be lucky because i
didn't see the first one
so it's going to be fresh i'll watch the
first one and i get to watch the other
one so with all these shows
hbo max has everything that you love all
in one place
for only 14.99 a month ad free
and you can also download all these
titles if you're on the go and you're
not able to have internet so stream all
of your favorites and maybe even find
some new ones
and sign up today by going to h b o m
dot a x slash o t r august that's h
b o m dot a x slash o
t r august margaret cho
first of all guest starred on good
trouble for a handful of episodes and
she is a dream yeah it and then like i
also do stand up and like and she i did
a show with her recently and like it's
just like this full circle
moment of like you know she is the
original bisexual stand-up female
asian comic and like it's just to
to be able to know her now to like have
her phone number you're gonna be like
that's crazy yeah what's her phone
number
[Laughter]
it's more of a you know uh mentorship
big sister's high b
um so anyway yeah i i
don't necessarily feel pressure in that
sense i am i'm happy to feel the
pressure
i want the pressure i want that fire
it motivates you which is why i do so
many like panels and like you know i i'm
writing op-eds i'm like making a keynote
speech you know what i mean it's like i
want to spread the word
and because that ripple effect is real
like you know we we were so trained to
like not use our voice
for so long that like now that we're
finally using it it inspires others to
do the same and like
you know you really see some people just
shut up though right yeah
no no one here we should always keep
talking the six of us
um but yeah i'm just so fired up you
know i feel like we should not settle
for
what we've been given like it blows my
mind that you know we haven't
had representation like everyone else
you know it's like what the [ __ ] we were
okay with it
to be honest we were because we thought
we couldn't do anything about it but now
especially with the community just like
truly being a force together like i feel
like we're really gonna make some
changes so i i always like to talk about
it
when we first started we're super about
pushing the asian american peoples
then there's all these people that
became other youtubers and they started
stealing our views and we decided to not
do that anymore
we're like nope we're gonna be the only
asians in town everyone be quiet right
well you know i have to shout i have to
shout out youtube
too because all of you like i'm i'm so
impressed
by y'all's like journey because it's
like when
hollywood wasn't giving asian people a
platform like
youtube did we have no other place to go
yeah y'all were self-made and like
you know i i definitely was familiar
with
your work before i met you you know you
know what's so funny though
we're so [ __ ] dumb we i don't even
think we knew what we're doing like we
didn't know that like okay this is the
anti-hollywood
path like a lot of people are very
intentional right like this is the
anti-hollywood path they're not going to
give me a voice they're not writing
roles for me
this is what i'm going to do
alternatively i think me and joe are
just like let's [ __ ] make each other
they feel like we're going to make fun
of korean people
yeah professional simple minded and then
it became like this bigger thing and
they were like oh [ __ ] there's
like some responsibility here i don't we
don't know about like asian voices
because we grew up in areas where
we that's all we were right i mean they
grew up in the 626 area and you know
and there's still asian voices to me
that haven't been heard exactly you know
there's only
the first layer yes but there's still
like layer two three four five in cells
have not been heard yet no
oh yes they have not been represented
right well yeah and that's the thing
like
and i'm always repping 66 everywhere i
go like i'm so proud that i grew up in
the san gabriel valley we're so lucky to
have been like immersed in our culture
and not be like the odd one out
you know like someone who grew up in
ohio like literally had no asian faces
anywhere um but also within the asian
community like
i'm you know i had a lot of friends who
were cool who were hot and stuff like
that you know it did take me a while to
find my voice even
within asian people you know um
that's it
so watch shang chi and the legend of the
ten rings
coming there has never been a martial
arts film ever in hollywood dude how
[ __ ] dare you dude that's crazy right
it's the first one martial arts movie we
got a shinji we got snake eyes
mortal kombat what are your favorite
sneakers
all martial arts i don't like no [ __ ]
we're pushing the boundaries guys
pushing the boundaries mysticism and
martial arts we want we got danger boys
you know
oh [ __ ] yeah but no one wants to [ __ ]
green like that
danger boys blue by you by justin chan
is going to be yeah
can't wait he is brilliant he is truly
really good at what he [ __ ] does
he's working on a project i think with
uh brian emanuel right now too oh no
cool hell yeah i love the 88 rising
votes yeah
they're really cool and i really hope
the coachella lineup stays how it was
because they were about to take over in
a major way like the original one that
didn't happen
it was like nikki joji and brian were
performing and they on saturday there
was going to be this 88 rising like
event
so i hope they i hope they still that's
[ __ ] dope i hope they don't silence
um
asians joji was so funny like i remember
him when he was uh
doing like filthy frank filthy phil yeah
it's so [ __ ] funny it was crazy
like you can't really have that on
youtube now yeah but um the [ __ ] that he
was doing
youtube gives and youtube takes [ __ ]
sake
the harlem the harlem [ __ ] the what is
it the harlem shake dance
oh the challenge one that you have the
harlem what's that called yeah
yeah and everyone falls right in what
happens oh no it's this thing
oh yeah that thing harlem hustle harlem
shuffle no it was the harlem shape but
the harmonica was already a thing
yeah no but he did the challenge one
sure where everyone just like
everyone was doing that yeah it's like
someone in a bedroom and then it cuts to
like going berserk
oh that one yeah what was your favorite
internet trend
pranks dude all the way dude baby i'm
saying where you would walk up and you
would just [ __ ] everybody's day up
lovely no cause oh my god speaking of
pranks remember planking
oh that was pretty funny i like planking
a
lot
that was ridiculous that was just the
beginning of the internet in terms of
rhyming it rhymed
come from like the whole planking thing
a genius stupid kids
i laugh my ass off at planking videos i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll own that i'm
liking videos
or we'll just like they'll pan to
somebody oh yeah
people were people were kind of might be
a bad look for you now but they were
attributed to like slavery
what i don't think it was true
they were they're saying like slaves in
the ship were stacked on top of each
other
oh come on that's a stretch i think i
think that's people were trying to make
it into
something like that to cancel it the
cancer or something like that well it
got canceled anyway
it's kind of boring well people started
getting hurt petered out yeah yeah
people started thinking doing doing it
really stupidly and they were getting
like really hurt
so people like what the [ __ ] stop the
[ __ ] oh yeah it's dangerous i saw a guy
who was like doing it on top of this
bill there was the
lava trend thing hot lava where they
would have to jump into
jump on [ __ ] i think they still do that
kind of [ __ ] oh do they that's just how
kids play
yeah but adults are doing it now in like
grocery stores and jumping into like
water bottle stacks like god dude
like jackass [ __ ] i always feel so bad
when they just ruin innocent businesses
they go and knock over
i know i know but i'm still crying in
tears like while i'm judging them
yeah me too i'm like oh that's so funny
you're eating the ice cream and you're
putting it back ah it's hilarious
yeah yeah why do people do that they
should just like
i will go to the store and like a drink
is like half [ __ ] full
optimist
but yeah like i think they get thirsty
because they're because they're poor
you're rich now you don't know what it's
like to be poor no but i feel so guilty
i have such a [ __ ] this little
five-year-old kid drinking this snapple
that's stealing david hey was aladdin
stealing when he took that bread broke
into heaven gave it to those two
fine fine fine fine fine what's the last
thing you stole what's the last thing
you all stole
your heart yeah you're gonna give it
back
can we boost somebody wow hit the boo
butt
she's like the friend that you tell you
should try stand up
to see if you crash a bird it was not
something y'all stole something
high school i accidentally walked out of
a grocery store with a toothbrush
because i was on the phone
there you go yeah high school we're in
hawaii we're getting food for dinner
at that grocery store and i left with
chocolates in my pocket
chocolate oh this was very recent
chocolates in your pocket
chocolates in my pocket chocolates in my
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't want to drive i always felt
bad for stealing because my parents
owned a small business
so when i would steal or think about
stealing i think about my parents first
so it was really hard
but then somebody told me it's walmart
bro
and that's what my life changed dude
everything in my phone are you serious
no i'm kidding i never steal anything
from a small business
you know yeah um well walton's yes my
parents went to black beauty supply
store
oh nice yeah yeah so we still like
leaves and wigs out in sacramento
california
is that where you're from yeah okay we
should get together one-on-one anyway
so i can start braiding her hair on the
block so what you gonna get into today
huh wait do you know how to do braided
braids uh not anymore i used to be able
to do it
because i was bored at the store and
then i could braid like regular hair but
i can't do a cornrows anymore gotta get
it we'll be in touch i used to do my
nails in the store and i used to [ __ ]
braid here
i love it oh wait don't your parents own
your favorite restaurant
because my parents own a restaurant i'm
very forgiving of like
a bug in my food it's that style of
restaurant i'm talking about flies
around the water
these pools took me to the most
disgusting restaurant it wasn't it
wasn't your parents
it's this other one called don san
gabriel valley yes i won't say it
because i'm trying to you know wreck
that business but i'm talking about
the the water container was literally
above a dumpster
and he was like where's the water he
goes next to the garbage can with the
flies
i'm like come on and i'm talking about
the you know the spit glass
it looks like the spit guys had glaucoma
you can't see through the food wow
you can't see it's [ __ ] delicious it's
delicious five dollars for 18 pounds of
food
there's nothing wrong with it like my
mom charges nothing
and she'll hand feed you it's like you
you get the best [ __ ] meal for the
ingredients at a market to your parents
yeah we should all go yeah whenever i
just open the tables again
whenever i go to a bathroom at a store
i'm always like oh yeah well my parents
had a public restroom so
yeah yeah yeah yeah makes you think
about that
so you flush it yeah i do and i clean it
up a little bit that's nice
god honestly poop stuff oh yeah
you